Yeah,
well my great inspiration in my life or
sort of two forces,
one was a religion which is very,
very important,
particularly for my mother and father,
but also for the members of our family
and has been incredibly important in
terms of my life,
uh,
particularly facing some of the real
challenging times that I've had to face
members of my family that had been lost
and other kinds of tragedies.
And also the role of family.
We were a large,
a large family.
I was the youngest of nine the last to
come along a sat at the little table on
the side of the room.
Always had to battle to get my views
across or to be able to express it.
But I had a extraordinary role models.
My father who is very,
uh,
ambitious for his children and it was a
great to support her mother who was the
safe haven devoted to her faith and also
the love of history.
Uh,
and uh,
her children.
My older brothers who were a great
heroes of mine and we're inspiring
figures all the way through my life.
Also demonstrated to me that the
political process could work and could
be responsive to people's needs and
challenges.
My sisters who in their own way,
uh,
we're not elected to any office,
but I'm also were very important in
terms of their own commitment,
uh,
in expanding opportunity for people.
My sister Eunice Shriver,
the founder Special Olympics now and a
144 countries and going to be a world a
focus in,
in China.
And just a few weeks from now,
uh,
my sister Jean,
who worked for very special arts
programs,
which has been so important in helping
people with the disabilities and also
who are artists to work and collaborate
together.
And uh,
my other sisters and I was also inspired
by a,
uh,
an oldest sister rosemary who was
mentally retarded and she was a,
a very important figure in our family.
And she was very included.
And I think,
uh,
from the earliest days I recognize the,
that she was a rather special individual
and I could see how my mother and father
had,
how my brothers and sisters reacted to
her.
And I think it was a,
probably a extraordinary force in my
life,
uh,
about,
recognizing the value and the,
a special grace that individuals have
that have a physical or challenges in
this instant mental retardation and the
importance,
uh,
their value and what they could give to
the family.
And also the recognition that,
uh,
people,
out there in our society have a special
needs and,
uh,
they as a,
as a family and as a,
as a country and a society,
we ought to be able to try and reach out
to our fellow citizens and to respond to
those kinds of,
um,
uh,
of human needs.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah,
I,
I do,
uh,
I think there are those that,
um,
uh,
in the,
in the congress elected office,
I see them,
I think they are in legislative,
uh,
offices,
as well.
I think they're out there.
And in the,
uh,
in the,
in the countryside is not necessarily
always in the house of the Senate.
I think state legislators or we see it,
we see it with district attorneys,
we see it in the local communities.
Um,
people,
one of the,
uh,
events that,
I'm always inspired of is when a
Caroline Kennedy,
my niece,
uh,
gives the a profile in courage award
day,
uh,
each,
year to an elected official.
And it's,
um,
uh,
we,
I've been on the judging,
uh,
as a judge in there.
And we spend a lot of time in looking
over these final recommendations.
And it's inspiring about,
uh,
what,
how willing people are to stand up and
take a.